we're going to turn now to new
information about the death of a Navy
SEAL recruit earlier this year Kyle
Mullen you may remember the name he was
a seal candidate he died in February of
acute pneumonia just hours after
completing the infamous hell week known
for pushing trainees to their absolute
limits as David Martin reports three
Navy officers have been disciplined now
for overseeing the training that
resulted in mullen's death
eight hours after these seal recruits
struggled out of the water to complete
the last agonizing steps of hell week
one of them Kyle Mullen was dead of
acute pneumonia his mother Regina can
pick him out in a freeze frame my son
was towards the end he's being carried
by another man he was barely able to
walk and breathe an investigation found
that after five days of what the Navy
calls extreme stress in a controlled
environment Mullen was so short of
breath and his legs so swollen he had to
be given oxygen twice and move from one
location to another by ambulance
but he was still declared fit to train
my son wasn't treated medically by the
medical team by their own
invest life
that's denied medical treatment right
there according to the investigation
Mullen had to be taken to the barracks
in a wheelchair he appeared to be
gasping for air super swollen with
bluish colored skin and fluids coming
from his mouth recruits had been assured
the duty medical officer we'll see you
at any time but when they called they
were told to dial 9-1-1 oh you could
call 9-1-1 they should have ran there
and checked them two officers in charge
of SEAL training received career
damaging warning letters one of them was
also in charge when this video captured
seal recruits being blanketed with tear
gas at point-blank range for a full
minute
even though the rules Clearly say it
should last no more than 15 seconds
this video was shot during the Final
Phase of seal qualification
Kyle Mullen died before he got that far
for CBS morning's David Martin the
Pentagon